yeah hello and welcome to this video
which is the final one for the World
Chess Championships 2016 between Magnus
Carlsen the defending champion and
Challenger segi kayaking now the final
video it is for sure because it's about
the tie breaks and after this day of
rapid and possibly blitz chess it's
clear with winning the match so let's
get right into it I'm uncovering a
couple of games in this video and in
order to not make it like extremely long
I'm going to focus on the most important
moments and and key situations and in
the very first game and we have a rapid
time control of 25 minutes per player
plus a 10 second increment the first
game on the Challenger had white so
we're going to start right away and this
is one of the games that I'm not
covering in much detail but let's let's
see what happens i want to show still
some key points we have this line again
the 63 Rui this has been the main
battleground in KY Atkins White's games
and to be perfectly honest I don't get
it I just don't get it how can you
repeat this line like for the I don't
know fifth time or something I didn't
look it up never get anything and in
some games actually be worse I mean
Carlton has outplayed him from that in
game what was that game for that was
actually a different different line but
it was a very similar structure so I
simply don't get why in a situation but
you should finally start a win a game
why not do something a little bit
different yeah I mean he can play one
idea three or c4 or whatnot Yemm why has
it why must it be the same line every
time not getting anywhere and we're
obviously team Carlton has new ideas
every game so we will see this here
again as Carleton Place night p 8 this
is not a bad move at all but it is a
relatively rare move
and it is new for the match in former
games Carlton had played 9 a-5 and
Bishop e6 and equalized with both of
them yeah now this time night PA tande
dis apparently also equalizes so sorry I
don't get it well I repeat the lame
opening all over again and never get
anywhere so we see that a couple of
moves later Black has expanded on the
queenside and also no yeah that Carlton
is much ahead on the clock so he's
springing new ideas every game and
doesn't doesn't have to use time so
sorry i don't get the preparation here
why repeat something that obviously
doesn't let anything all over again i'm
speaking about the position um yeah
black has gained some space on the
queenside and has developed all this
piece I think the position should be
roughly equal there are some interesting
points that white has displayed Bishop
to c4 an important thing to notice that
it is never a good idea for black to
take on c4 and give wipe those double
bonds this is something that is often
misunderstood double points can be
weaknesses but they don't don't have to
be weaknesses all of the time here for
example white is very happy with this
configuration where the sea three Pawn
covers very important squares if I mean
this would be cooperative but let's just
do this also yeah here we see that those
pawns are symmetrical but the c3 pong is
a huge difference it covers those two
weeks squares or there would be weak if
the pawn is not on c3 on the black side
or ever be five and d5 are weak so here
white could try I mean it's not easy to
accomplish or it would take a long time
but why could try to let's say put
nights on those squares while black
cannot do the same so this is an
important thing to consider double
points often cover important squares
here they are not we get on as they
cannot be attacked
how should not ever attack those pawns
yeah this could happen in I don't know
deep in the rook ending where white
somehow has blundered control of the
beef I'll sounds very unlikely so black
does not want to take their they both
them centralizer a bit more pieces and
here like maybe tries to play d5
kayaking decided to trade and now I'm
contemplate ft 6 move that was a bit
surprising to me and also to the
commentators um but it seems perfectly
okay when once you look at the game it
looked a little bit like he had prepared
this recapture I don't know maybe he did
not like the prospect of white playing
c4 he shuts down the whole game like on
this area of the board everything now is
it shut down well why it might be easier
it might be easier for white to prepare
something on the on the King side it is
probably roughly equal still but maybe
he disliked that this move is fine
however there's nothing wrong with it we
now get some trades and black activates
with root before this is an absolute key
idea the look jumps to this square
looking at the pond and more importantly
the a4 pawn and in fact there is not
much else now then to trade dissolve and
now we get something check is very well
known if we have four pawns or identical
porn count on one flank like he adds on
the Kings side or I okay this is not
technically the King side but yeah we
have to pawn masses that are directly
opposed there's no passer anywhere it's
very difficult to get to something
concrete um Black is just extremely
solid too even though he has a slightly
weaker pawn structure with the f porn
missing they continued a couple of more
moves but
simply not much going on here they
agreed to a draw so not a very exciting
game but still I find it remarkable that
kayaking is repeating the same
completely unpromising line or all over
again I understand that there's nothing
particularly great that why I can do why
he has problems proving advantages in
any opening where black plays a good
main line but why hit hit the same spot
every time or you get nowhere yeah and
ok anyway let's see what happened in
game 2 which was a lot more interesting
we get the Italian this time when Carla
is playing a form as well but he at
least varied a little bit yeah he tried
to d force he tried the Italian once ok
and in this game we have a repeat of a
couple of moves from game I don't know
didn't make a note what game that was
Game five yeah we are identical up to
this point and before was played in the
in the fifth game really not sure about
the count I think I'm fine and this time
Carleton Place rookie won the should 287
age 3 all this is very very standard
black gets the night over to g6 and I
have to say that I usually have these
kind of positions with the black pieces
and I am always like from back home
Beckham in the days when I started to
play you 45 as black which is like
roughly 10 11 years ago I never
considered this to be particularly
threatening always thought okay the
Italian will see three thats that's
extremely lame Black has no problems
yeah I put the night that here on g6 I
play c6 but i have to say that i'm
having now a bit more experience with
the position
I tend to I tend to feel that white
sometimes has a little something he's a
little bit better coordinated and
somehow even I mean the night is clearly
not great on c6 if we go back as it
looks at all those control control with
squares so reroute it definitely makes
some sense on the other hand sometimes I
feel on g6 it's obviously not to bring
that much and we will see a situation a
couple of moves later if we just fast
forward a little bit yeah if we go to
this position here we see that somehow
why it is much better equipped to do
something on the queenside the light on
c4 makes a much stronger impression than
this night I mean if we look at the
pawns the pods are completely
symmetrical okay we have h 3 plate but
that's not a big difference if black
plays h6 or not doesn't really matter
that much it's a bit it's a little
difference but it's it's not a big big
thing but if we compare White has the
night on c4 against the night OMG 6 and
this is a little bit a little bit
annoying for black and white somehow is
the more active part in looking at those
two pawns on e5 and 85 so I don't think
that luck has equalized completely even
though you would think that not not much
happens and it should not really be a
big issue from black but as we see it
it's not easy to handle the kayaking
plate Queen to c7 and our Carlton with
before yeah he can play this kind of
advanced here and black him for black
it's more difficult to do so it's it's
funny that I mean kayaking now played
the obvious looking move captures on
before it's funny that computers
actually want to ignore the capture yeah
my stock fish so then this is brew
suggest something like age 68
and just claims that this should be fine
but this is such an outlandish idea
that's never going to be played in human
game especially with a quite limited
time control like rapid yeah that one
ideas to play c4 and why cannot take it
is really a little bit bit strange the
engine gives moves like this and then
once the place you form an IT towards
its various very strange um the normal
who is to capture and this is what I a
candid and now he played b5 trying to
solve his problems bye-bye tactical
means yeah why problems instead really a
problematic position for black mean it's
not something huge but well what is he
supposed to do let's say he plays some
some some slow move let's say a rupee
eight or something okay he actually
Bishop e2 is a bit annoying yeah but we
can we can show that him like this and
then a five is this kind of structure 95
also as an interesting move but this
structure white gets in a 5 this is
annoying if you play be six then you'll
see six point would be very weak and a
move like c5 is downright don't write a
catastrophic after b5 Wow yeah what wins
probably so white wants to establish
this bind with a five and it's not easy
really not easy he played the five but
that also does not seem to equalize
Carlton just dropped back to e3 and now
the question is what to do with this
pawn on d5 it's really not easy really
not easier I mean it's a it's a pin down
on the C file so why--just threatens to
win this for for good um yeah but what
is he supposed to play again computers
give some outlandish lines yeah Queenie
seven trying to take before giving the
exchange but even that I have to slice
some
in my notes let me check in I don't want
to like just called computer lines but
this is a funny one queen is seven air
and and a five and now black actually
has to check if he allows wipe this upon
which is another strategic threat that
white has yeah then it's just were so
kicks and then something like this is
what the computer gives but YTM has the
better the better chances and he will
win the exchange and keep the ape on the
computer line is actually really funny
it gives something like this bishop of
eight hook f8 queen takes and now he was
answered with the extremely funny move
g3 hit at the counter decking Queen
takes Bishop e2 and the Queen doesn't
have squares 95 it takes and again the
Queen doesn't have squares but black can
save himself with this funny move about
after Bishop tweenage five and a six why
this better yeah it get completely crazy
line but also not really giving black
full equality hey I can decided to take
on a four after long think after which
is settled with that weak pawn and the
problem is it's very difficult to get
rid of it because every c5 yeah that's a
c5 immediately is almost always going to
be answered by b5 and this is a very
very bad structure for black that porn
is much more dangerous than the C porn
because whitey has very easy ideas
Bishop c4 95 you can use this piece as
much better on the queenside then black
can use his pieces especially the GG 696
light doesn't do anything if this would
sit somewhere on the queenside to defend
it's a different story but here why just
opens the position favorably on the side
of the board where he has more pieces
yeah kayaking out took only three that's
not easier I mean he did that's
relatively quickly but the decision
probably was made a bit
young and yeah he's under heavy pressure
and he's got about timeless advantage of
ten minutes he the icons will be
captured with the bishop this is
stronger than hook takes rook takes
isn't actually bad the ideas that after
the trade him the root actually covers
this but what I think what he played is
just much more dynamic like this this he
gave up that part and now kadrik see one
it's very strong this pawn is attacked
and black has no a really great way to
cover it we should note that white is
also threatening the move be five which
is the discovery on this night so let's
say black would play a move like that
like 97 I think what your duty do we
should be five right let me check the
abbey should be five it move like that
is answered it would be five and this is
an attack on the night after the night
gets covered white can actually push to
be 6 and this position is bad for black
there's absolutely no way around that
the beep on is extremely strong and it's
if you are in a game with very limited
time and you see a line like that you
you almost certainly know that you are
worse probably much worse and
potentially you are losing I mean this
is really possible so it's not a line
that you would like to play he decided
to play Bishop g5 preparing a complete
transformation of the position of tv5
and this is a quite typical way of
defending that way I can used a lot in
this match he is essentially trying to
defend us in a fortress style how does
that happen yeah he now decided to
capture on d5 get rid of the beep on so
there's no beep on promoting now anymore
we are reduced in terms of pawns on the
King side ok all kinds of things are
hanging the key point is that why don't
let's the move Queen takes e4 which was
played by Carlton the Queen gets a
desperado uniform and now we see that
with this attack yet Black has to check
on c1 and white takes on
five so what do we have that Green has
to move let's get that steak stock here
that is what pie I can aim for when you
played to move Bishop t5 now we are
reduced to the Kings side and this is a
typical way of building a fortress you
try to reduce the play to one side of
the board and just try to build up
something that the other side is not
able to to break down however white is
clearly better in this position he has
got three minor pieces to bishops
against rook and pawn so he is much
better here and we cannot say is winning
but it's a very very substantial
advantage the reason is quite often that
the number of pieces the piece count is
very important because you can build up
combined threats of those pieces for
example against the black king or
against upon weaknesses that you had
that you have to attack or that I'm
being being created um we see after a
couple of texture on the White Queen
can't manage to put the Queen on reform
and activate this position now the move
aged four instead of g3 also was
interesting but I think we cannot cannot
really fault him for any decision here
everything is good now yeah he played
the move Bishop before a bit surprising
because after Queen e6 the white queen
is running a little bit short of squares
and they were interesting alternatives
here he could still play the move Knight
age for for example that was an
interesting tribe after which black
probably has to go back if he takes
between age seven seems to be hard too
dangerous but 9 f8 is playable yeah well
he played this move community six and
now queen age five the thing is after
the Queen trade it is not clear if white
can win he is certainly able to try
forever but win like a mathematical will
prove it difficult teen aged five we
have to note that cards and had roughly
here eight minutes I think this is
roughly correct against Kuryakin was
yeah a little bit later
getting down to the increment so Carlton
has a much better position and a much
better time 97 now by kayaking and now a
surprising decision by by Carlton he did
not go for yeah he did not continue
let's say with all the pieces on the
board and which was possible an
interesting move that suggested by
computers is 95 certainly a move that
that they that he checked however there
are some quite outlandish ideas here
again which seemed okay for a computer
but for a human player not easy first of
all black cannot take this this is this
gently to see check check yeah and here
we see that two bishops can be pretty
strong here basically everything get
lost him like this is a check way to win
easily for what this is not the problem
line the the line that is difficult is
this one like moves the Queen away he
has to keep f7 protected yeah now the
engines given like that check king of
eight and now 94 and these are lines
that are difficult to play for for human
player I mean they are obviously quite
attractive looking but this is not very
harmonious and at the bishop 187 we
should note that there are some funny
and funny tactics in this position for
example why it is actually threatening
one yeah it depends on the on blacksmith
now of course but something that really
takes h6 pawn takes Bishop takes would
actually be made yeah if we just just
for fun there this would be a fun
technique funny check made now it's
dangerous but it's not so easy to assess
still it was surprising to see that
cards opted for Queen txt file he also
could have played other moves yeah well
okay he took this and now 96 and again
we see that
is a good defense by kayaking we have
those pieces slide up now on the e-file
so this is forced and now we have an
ending to bishops against a single rook
I did not have the time to look up if it
has been analyzed in some and some depth
my gut feeling was that this should be a
draw which was supported by some some
grandmasters during the during the game
I'm not sure if we land and Gustafson
also believed it could be a draw but
there are also some tweets I I think
it's not unreasonable to assume that it
should be a draw it's not easy four
wives to really make some progress
however let's go handle all jack we have
to note that kayaking was living on the
increment basically fast forward a
little bit and we see that Carlton has
made some progress and yes managed to
activate your skin and enter on the key
inside and in fact we will come to a
situation where he has given up this
prank black could not go the other way
check drop this pawn and now we see
blacks King now is in some danger he is
on h8 for it is on age 8 and something
like this actually is made that is one
winning idea that dead white has and
here I'm Jim Bishop 26 that was played
rookie to we come to a critical moment
Carson still has some time I'm not sure
if four minutes are correct but yet
substantial time three minutes something
like that and surprisingly you did not
find the winning line now this is I
think really surprised and surprising
because it is not that difficult to do
white no wins with King f7
and the idea is to play for playful mate
so how can black possibly defend the
only possible on defense IAM is to check
on the seventh-ranked so like guqin roxy
to is the most challenging challenging
line and now that actually I'm the
difficult thing is to see the movie form
I mean this actually after Luke's
javelin King here and then f5 is not
that clear because after King takes
white has one upon but it is not clear
that we have actually gained all that
much the key thing is that white in this
position has the time to play d4 because
black has no useful move if he plays
after G form and some sort of non move
then white is going in for the kill we
should have aid check and now the move
f5 can be answered with GTX and here
black has no defense against bishop f7
and Bishop g7 mate for example h5 f6
takes Bishop f7 and this is funny right
Bishop g7 mate so this is the wind for
white note that it's a very close call
yeah yeah we have a dark squared corner
here and it's a dark squared bishop this
will be relevant later so this was this
was actually winning for what but Carson
did not see that surprisingly i think
it's it's not fun to play off that level
it's not that difficult to do you played
Bishop g4 back and now this is this
whole thing that's entering with the
King giving up the f1 didn't didn't
all that much now the position
objectively is a draw however it's still
not easy to do pro black arena to defend
we can again fast forward a little bit a
couple of moves check and we have think
here almost King g8 bishop here yeah and
here and kayaking should play rook c6
king edge aid one of those moves but
yeah being low on time now they both
didn't have much time I think here the
clocks are actually not correct i think
they had last time he played the movie
seven and again in this position Carson
can win but he didn't have much time and
he can win back with the same thing
actually that we have seen earlier yet
black is completely powerless against
the bishop of seven and Bishop g7 made
and again that was not played even with
like 30 seconds or so I mean those those
players are so good okay it didn't it
didn't happen but should be six in a
little bit of back and forth check yeah
and now you don't really make any
progress unless you do this and here
kayaking found with limited time a
drawing I diem h5 what is the point it
is really is really strong move white
now I should probably take a move like
g5 I mean this also has no winning ideas
and this pawn might even prove dangerous
oh gee cakes and how does he draw now
yeah he draws with f5 dropping the spawn
and not taking yeah and it's a fortress
okay yeah he's the man with the
fortresses and what is black doing here
exactly nothing he just shuffled back
and forth and white has no way forward
the reason is he has to age pawns and
those are useless with a light squared
Bishop am
but there is nothing to do here after g5
the draw was a grease calmate okay it
was still taken on bustle yeah it is
always a draw a stalemate and you cannot
I mean you simply cannot win with an H
born it's the problem and whatever you
do you will always sound like here yeah
you can go back snatch this pawn it's
just a draw it's wrong the wrong colored
bishop so in extremely narrow escape
here by the Challenger cards had to
clear clearly winning continuations in
this in descending and he had an
extremely good middle game that Milligan
was wrong but when the queens were still
on the board I mean it was an attacking
position with bigger taking shots so
Carson had a huge time advantage to use
huge advantage on the board still did
not within the game so heavy blow I
think for the world champion not taking
the deep down so we went into Game 3
with kayaking having white and it's no
surprise he played the same line again
yeah so again you can maybe he was it
called fast forward no fast backward or
something go back to what I said with
Game one I think I think actually if he
plays this against Carlin 50 games he
won't win a single one yeah i'm a maybe
maybe one or so because some sometimes
black falls asleep or something but i
don't see the point why why no why no
variety anyway so um cousin actually
plays and again a new idea they have
like obviously a ton of ideas against
this this this and this should be six we
had seen actually and now be four
playback kayaking 96 95 94 it's a little
bit comparable to what we had in Game
are 11
in terms of ideas but there's some
differences before and we should a tool
and okay let's let's get right to the
action kayaking now actually plays a
sharp 95 this is one of the very few
decisions in his match where we can say
that he played the most principled
active move he quite often didn't do
that and I think this is a real floor if
you challenge for the world title and
play as safely as he does I don't know I
think you should should be more
aggressive anyway 95 that's a that's an
interesting move the bishop is now under
attack on e6 and Carla took this and he
played and played the opening so
relatively quickly takes takes Knight to
d7 94 and we have to be aware that the
knight on d4 is an absolute keep easier
it has very little squares actually if
black now is not playing in the way he
does then black will end up in a bad
position council place f5 very
aggressively and he has to basically if
you play something something lame and
let's play some lame move and the light
is this being kicked back back to f5
that really didn't make any sense the
night now here has a simply a bad square
and nowhere to go to and why it should
be better in this position he's got the
two bishops currently this Bishop is not
looking great but it can be improved for
example it can be sometimes put on this
diagonal and then d4 can happen here
black is just worse so we have to go f5
perfectly knowing that now the night has
no square at all so f5 basically commits
you to play f4 and this is a very highly
committal kind of decision yeah black
pushing forward like that I'm absolutely
um
skeptical about the clock times here by
the way that I displayed I think Calvin
did not spend that much time okay so he
pushed the F point forward this is very
committal Black is gaining space on the
Kings side but gives away in a way I
mean gives away you never have to
control it now these squares here are
firmly invites control especially for um
very committal but also ambitious this
is what I'm talking about you have to at
one point like yeah just just grab the
initiative and try something and this is
what he is doing he is playing very
enterprising here with the f porn push
so see 39 f 594 centralizing the night
yeah Queen to d8 and we have for now
some idea what black is is up to and
then like this this for example can be
an attacking scheme on on a very good
day you can actually even push the pawns
but that must be a very good day so it's
more about a piece basement based attack
on the kingside the next decision but
hey I can was so not this one actually
the dead did make some sense yeah get
the bishop around maybe prepare a for
prepare gay too we do six the next
decision was met with some criticism
with them from from Peter Svidler and
who didn't like it he advocated King
edge one here to have group g1 in case
of an attack and he didn't like them who
have three at all um which shows him I
mean I I kind of hmm I was kind of
thinking who know not not great to do
that but he was highly critical and said
okay you know this weekend c3 long-term
and you simply don't want to give this
piece of square and he showed them I
mean he's a great player he showed a
very good insight as we will see that
this in fact will become an issue later
um bishop age for this bishop didn't do
much on yourself
and from on edge form it actually has
some active ideas it typically checking
idea for example can be to simply put it
on g3 so I just I just make some random
moves now to show the idea it isn't it
doesn't really work yet but i just want
to show it this pawn then would be the
base for Queen edge to mate and with
proper preparation this can be quite
dangerous no taking idea that is well
known from from openings like em the
Kings Indian or sometimes even the
sveshnikov and so what happened here a
four white lead some play on the on the
queenside Knight f6 this night is also
coming towards the King side and Queen
to d2 yeah we have roughly equal clock
times now ya know I think a very good
decision by by Carlton if we look at
this position in terms of board area so
like if you look at this area of the
board basically the kingside black looks
to be far more active the only danger
that might come to him to black is
something on the queenside where those
pawns look somewhat vulnerable for
example if this position would be
slightly different and black would have
let say the pawn back on b7 then I think
it would be quite clear that black is
for choice because the play on the King
side will be dangerous I mean you have
lots of pieces around and white has no
clear counter play with the pawn back on
b7 I think black would be fine i'll be
very very fine better so the Queen side
is the danger that there's something
happening here so it plays a five very
nice trying to just get rid of all the
points here so that in a way like okay
let's let's make a let make sure that
nothing happens there and then we can
look to play on the kingside not easy to
react to this it's a very very tough
decision now because this point
there are simply many options for white
and it's difficult to say but maybe the
next choice by kayaking wasn't the best
he took on b5 maybe it was better to
take on a five I mean a difference en I
mean one thing is that it looks at an
awkward because of the pin but
ultimately afternoon flat book a 2 and
this gets traded this position should be
somewhat should be roughly equal still
the difference to the to the game is if
we look at this a b5 a be for now the
sea pawn will be moving it has to react
to the B point in some way and then they
are actually more weaknesses on the
queenside yeah bishop t two cakes takes
and now we see that those pawns are not
particularly active yeah it's not a good
structure not like they would like for
one by one but it is it is quite
vulnerable so cousin played 93 this is
what's will go ahead set on a long
couple of moves ago then this square can
prove to be a long-term liability Roxy
one concentrated here and now Kate Queen
to d8 yeah asking white about this now
isolated pawn yeah my to cover it and
King edge hey this is a good movie on
King h8 getting out of this diagonal
shouldn't be underestimated if black for
example instead of 28 would play some
yeah but but quite sure what you want to
want to play let's play this kind of
thing you have to reckon with ideas of
Bishop Jake's e5 check this kind of this
kind of thing can prove to be extremely
dangerous when here queen bee sixes
probably work but this is an idea so
it's a good idea to put the King back
Queenie aid was also covering those
ideas so Knight f6 no but hey I can
this is a mistake which was not used by
my cousin he quite surprisingly took
with the bishop went quickly it seems
that GTX was very strong for black yeah
you have grouped g8 coming and this
attack can be very very dangerous to to
media note that the nidus is extremely
strong you did not take it with the Jeep
on surprisingly and you can look at
lines you like I went today what did I
do for example King h1 something like
this which looks normal yeah this for
example is already winning at queen age
5 and then you have this chick note that
those bishops I extremely bad pieces and
they absolutely don't help at all so
there was a strong strong idea but
wasn't playing he took with the bishop
ok 3 by ok I can try to make infiltrate
on the FR and now I'm yeah great move by
by the world champion you can play like
basically everything here with black and
be ok but what he did is a very
instructive move he played the movie
form taking into account that the bishop
was a relatively passive piece and now
we have a 4th line where this Bishop
gets traded because white really doesn't
have any big girl I cannot avoid the
bishop try again he took with this pawn
kicks kicks and now this so he has given
up a pond with this he got rid of the
dark squared bishop that means that the
dark squares are now much weaker in
whites camp and night now is not going
to be challenged by a bishop again so
the light is just sitting there always
near white skin attacking g2 and being
until the nuisance plus in the current
situation
the a file would be a possible way to
infiltrate there was a really nice movie
form objectively white might not be in
that bad shape the computer is insisting
that this is an equal position but in a
practical game this position is terrible
absolutely terrible for wide and it's no
big surprise that kayaking has big
problems here he has like two minutes on
the clock and with two minutes on the
clock this is hell yeah the night is
just a much more dangerous piece with
just a whistle with with them a little
time on the clock and here is also
objectively stronger than the white
Bishop is just just a dummy piece yeah
h3 this is probably not the best Queen
d2 was suggested by Sevilla and the
broadcast and I tend to agree that looks
like a very natural move to patch up
some dark squares still black has all
the options here and we have to see he's
running almost zero risk him he is a
pawn down but how are you hi am I going
to lose this position unless you like
yeah blunder Luke c7 or something like
that it's a not imaginable that white
again can get anything active done when
he played age three be age six this is
necessary in the long run I guess
additional King safety King age to the
kind of move that you play actually have
no time King h2ax queendom King su-24 we
need one Queen B to this is getting
critical now and the funny thing is that
here he played Bishop f1 computers
insists that Bishop e2 is the right
depends but here you can see why a
computer evaluation sometimes means
nothing because in a practical game
nobody is going to play that I'm showing
you this computer line because it is it
is extremely funny it should be to group
a two and this is actually the moment
where the human player basically stops I
mean maybe you calculate one one or two
moves further but this is only
I mean this only applies to people I
really really strong okay this is a text
if you move the bishop you're going to
get killed with this so are you just
losing the piece no you actually have an
idea b5 it's a really funny one of the
idea is that after pawn takes the first
of all if black takes on e 2 a.m. then
there's a breakthrough if you're white
Woods would actually yeah be able to
promote you spawn and for a draw problem
but this is this is good enough so let's
say the pawn takes this and why it goes
d6 just insisting on this breakthrough
okay takes check check check yeah and
now um yeah II form check g6 check yeah
and the funny thing is that here you
think that black might escape but why it
has the amazing resource book c2 which
draws so I mean nobody is calculating
like that especially when this is a
seven move deep line in a rapid game
it's totally unrealistic even if if you
have time on the clock you never find
this this is channel by perpetual yeah
okay he played Bishop everyone and it
seems that after Bishop f1 then the
position is objectively losing Luke a
choo um he could have defended better
now he played rook c7 with a min yet no
this is wrong and he didn't have to
millions he had seconds yeah and he
played rook c7 which loses immediately
but it's extremely difficult to defend
this and something like a rupee one back
we'll go to f6 on to be 35 and continue
to press him I think it's very unlikely
that this should hold in the long run I
mean computers a supercomputer I think
gave the windy and disposition but I
don't know those precise lines yeah he
played this and after hook a one
kayaking had to resign he loses this
Bishop with a check and yeah mate is not
how I think it is actually a maiden in
something so that was obviously an
extremely important point for the world
champion winning here with black giving
him the two to one lead in this
four-game mini match so that meant in
the final game he had to wipe pieces and
just needed a draw which is which sounds
very doable but it's something that
still has to be be done under the
circumstances so if I was played no
surprise that's the best shot for
playing for a draw there are so many
forced lines that you can use to draw
kayaking is going for this not if I've
anymore but probably aiming for either
night off or classical Sicilian maybe a
classical and because here when I'm
talking about is see him in the in the
night off there are actually tons of
ways for why to force draws not like
completely forcing ones but you can play
lines like with Bishop g5 where there
are many situations where white can come
out with a draw and this is what cards
and once in this position maybe he would
have gone here we don't know because
Carlton played the moves f3 this is an
interesting sideline and something that
I am think it could be could be worth
checking out if you want to have a kind
of little surprise weapon handy that is
not a much work in some cases on it
transposes to other position types now
for example if black plays let's say g6
you have a choice you can go for a roxy
bind start up position or you can
transpose to the to the dragon just the
main line dragon
if black plays e6 then white can go with
c4 again in amarok see style or can also
think about this and go for English
attack setup which black already has
committed to e6 so some interesting
points kayaking plate d 5 which is the
main moves I guess 93 Bishop e7 and ce4
why it just stops any d65 a five and a
four plates here buying the Challenger
and to be honest I'm not completely sure
how black should play this position I
mean I did not make a full theoretical
exploration of it I what I know is that
I think that blacks position pretty much
sucked in a couple of moves but I don't
really know what what the wrong idea was
I mean this decision my mind doesn't
look all that bad like try to fight for
some dark squares but somehow he does
not it seems that he is not able to
prevent the move before in the long run
and if that happens and you're simply
not in good shape maybe night asics was
questionable that was also questioned in
the broadcast but my notes are dropping
and it was also mentioned in the
broadcast that they had some doubts
about it but yeah it's time to same what
I know is that this position is good for
what yeah why does able to play B form
quite quickly and yeah it doesn't it
doesn't it's no fun and one thing by the
way that should be mentioned that is
that this move here no it's not here
there was a funny line let me check if I
can reconstruct that
I think it was here I didn't put that in
the notes here before that's a funny
idea here the black queen gets trapped
here they had this in the broadcast as a
funny line right so a three year was I
mean that that isn't even good strategic
David it is completely punished by
before yeah okay so in the game white
got to play before and this position is
very comfortable it's just very
comfortable black had to take now both
light takes and pawn takes are good
Cardin took with a pawn and Queen to d8
yeah 93 and 96 and the night wonders
with this long route over to d5 so what
we have here is a structure that in
principle is quite well known in the
caesarian from the night of and some
others the problem here for black is he
um has too much and he has too many
witnesses the missing a pawns they give
white also the b5 square and black does
not really have a very clear idea what
is counterplay might look like you
cannot play f5 in this position you
cannot play be five so i think i can
with this admit he had to play something
non-symmetrical something to to instill
some life into the position he drifted
into a bad position while while doing
that Bishop c6 and now black tried to
push the H porn try to for some for some
play but can't simply attacked this pawn
and now play g3 to activate his Bishop
there was not the only plan but it made
perfect sense the bishop on f1 is not a
very good piece why not activate it okay
okay three probably not the best choice
but it is difficult to give black some
advice he doubled on the air file and
now Carlton just attack
Brook and here threatened before that's
a very clever decision yeah 92 back
because yeah the best move from black is
actually looked to a six but this is the
repetition so clackin cannot do that
when yeah we have to say that here
cousin obviously we repeat because that
gives him the World Championship title
but why does of course just clearly
better if you place any other move like
whatever yeah this strategic advantage
is huge but he would of course take the
draw because of the general sporting
consideration yeah but kayaking cannot
allow it wrong he played b6 this is a
pretty bad move objectively and he knew
that it is not a good move but it is the
only move to continue it is bad because
it weakens even more on the whole Queen
side I also look I drifted into huge
time issues right okay it's difficult
are you sitting in a bad position you
need to win and you have no active ideas
so cars just took this pawn and this
night this was a somewhat controversial
decision a decision at least in the
broadcast because a young person didn't
like this for white because he felt like
he gives he opens up the King position
and gives black maybe some ideas about
Peter still have thought that white
should just be clearly better here and
it was fine and I kind of sweet let his
right I think objectively speaking but
what what I know is that I would be
slightly puzzled with white or
conservator survivor puzzle is wrong
concerned that something might happen a
key problem loafer black is that this
Bishop is not good and it's not easily
activated yeah okay three attacking the
pawn and now after this yeah black you
pretty much has to do what he did he
gave away the exchange now with who
takes me three but you're not going
anywhere with a move like that yeah why
just 10 secures the king
and I mean what's going on here Black is
a pawn down it has no compensation here
and can try to crunch I to activate but
wide White's position is very very
controlled and the night years putting
pressure it can be rebooted so that that
should be reasonably easy to handle so
root B 394 and now we have this
situation where black is an exchange
down for a pond and he has this hope
that this Bishop will activate but the
position now is reasonably easy for cars
into to play the porn went up to age 5
which is good preventing any g6 and
preventing anything like that with the
look coming to t5 later it is a very
good control that he has um yeah they
both didn't have much time kayaking was
down to yeah I think less than 50
seconds consulate cousin lock on two
minutes we come to an interesting
situation in her bid layer he could have
taken on air for by the way but this is
a good safe move takes it check check
and now that's very nice now yeah black
nope late Queen to f2 and Carlton now
decides on decides he took a moment they
had to calculate and we have to be
perfectly aware that in this position if
white just place the move let's say
Queen g3 he wins this in the long run
black is not made in here yeah something
like this route you want white will win
I mean technically win but he took a
moment and played a check with Roxy a
check he he saw the coming
coming things Luke ch-check black now
only has two legal moves that make sense
King age seven or bishop evade after
Bishop and aid check white takes oops
check and now crashes through the shadow
check mate check it's not rocket science
you know but you have to do this chatter
the decisive game in a World
Championship match and if you are
somewhat wrong here check checkmate this
is the main if you're somewhat wrong you
are going to get checkmated yeah black
has a ton of threads so you have to be
completely sure that this kind of line
does work kaikan did not do that you
played King age 7 and now we come to the
final move of this of this world
championship match and this I think it
is the most beautiful finish of a world
championship match to date it is some I
mean if you just like final move of a
match not the best move ever played in a
in a in a match but the final move of a
matches is the most beautiful one I
think if you think otherwise and have
some I've forgot something yeah please
I'm happy to learn about that in the
comments section yeah cards now played
the extremely beautiful move change 64
Queen sacrifice and it's extremely nice
to see you if the if the King takes we
have checkmate h8 checkmate and the only
other legal move is the pawn capture
check Nate which gives the second
checkmate yeah so it's very nice I mean
it's not extremely difficult or anything
but it is it's extremely static and it's
great that he that is he saw it in this
very limited time and went for it and
not for some prosaic win um this is
really beautiful so Carson wins check
this tiebreaker 31 um winning Game three
and Game four um and retains his title
if we look at
games and this tirade I think that was
extremely deserved victory if you look
at the tiebreak alone I mean um cars
already had a completely winning
position in Game two after got pretty
much out playing kayaking for most of
the game but then he failed to convert
which we have seen in the match as well
but then he came back on in Game three
when certainly if you are hand of the
world champ you could have some doubts
yeah again in spoiled the winning
position would he be able to focus on
really and alone steam and do something
something wacky and lose even know we
played a great game in Game three and
won convincingly with the black pieces
yeah and some septum stage for this
final game which really has to be seen
in that context I mean if you just look
at this game and wonder what did black
do here then you would say okay black
played extremely badly but thing is he
had to win and you have to take some
kind of non-symmetrical approach and it
certainly didn't work out I think every
was a clever choice so this game has to
be really put in context but 31 result
it's not unreasonable at all Carson had
two games where he outplayed kayaking
and was missing and we narrowly the
other one he did win and then he won
Game four so it was a very clean victory
in this tiebreaker I'm seeing this
performance him you kind of understand
the strategy a little bit better to
simply give away game 12 44 draw he said
in the past conference that they had
yeah they decided on the strategy and
started the preparation for the
tiebreaker the day before game 12 so
basically being confident that council
would make a draw at will with some some
line and they only focused on the
tiebreak while Tim kayaking had to also
do something for game 12 yet in case of
cars will try something in this regard
so this this very lame game 12 which
cost many understand
negative reaction probably the strategy
and yeah be paid off in some way um I
want to say about the overall match it
certainly wasn't the best match ever
some people wrote yeah it was the worst
match ever this is also certainly not
true um I think it was a pairing let's
say a matchup of two players let's do
this position in set of 2 players that
are somewhat similar in style and with
the extremely good preparation this
basically meant that then we will have a
pretty high draw read what i felt i was
somewhat too disappointed with us that
kayaking did not really make any
pressure with white I mean he played the
same Lane ruler passes all over again
where I mean he never won a white game
and and I think he also almost never
came close the only white game when he
had something was game 9 and this is one
game out of eight yeah total and the
other games he had absolutely zilch in
some cases he was even worse after the
opening and this is thing very
surprising or was very surprising to me
um the Carlin said in the press
conference that they focused a lot on
the black side of preparation to not get
into trouble I think they did this very
well Carl's never had any opening issue
of the black if you exclude that game
line was some but this was the game also
right after the loss so there were
certainly also some influence them I
think for a challenger has to show a
little bit more then then just and I
mean there's really am with all due
respect just tenacious defense you have
to be a bit more aggressive a bit more
attacking and a bit more willing to win
game since i mean he he certainly was
really to win games but i mean only
trying to win games from the defense is
a strategy that should normally not work
i mean there is this famous saying that
yeah tech wins games and defense wins
championships but of course you have to
be a good defender but you have to try
to yeah you need to outplay the other
guy once in a while and and kayaking did
not do that in this match I mean he won
Game eight after Carson / pressed and
where he used his chances very well okay
I can did not taking away anything from
him but if you look at like phases of
games where one side was out playing the
other Carlton has like I don't know
maybe seven or eight of those and
kayaking has one or two so I think even
the score was very very narrow but I
think if you just look at the games of
the garden is the very much deserved
winner of this of this event um yeah I
think I'm closing closing this coverage
now thanks a lot for for watching this
video and also the other videos I also
have to say and I will make a separate
video on that but I received quite some
donations over the last couple of weeks
when i covered the world championship
match I'm very very grateful for that
and I think it's very much connected to
the coverage of the match so thanks a
lot for although some donations ok I'll
be back with ya the regular daily daily
videos thanks for watching bye bye